ce dimanche le gymnase chastagner
d'elancourt n'a pas pu s'embraser lors
du 64ème de finale de coupe de france de
roller hockey la faute aux phénix de ris
orangis pensionnaire de nationale 2 soit
une division au-dessus d'isolant
courtois les joueurs essonniens prennent
rapidement le contrôle du match dépassés
certainement par le rythme des chocs
sont sanctionnés à de nombreuses
reprises et encaisse la plupart de leurs
buts en contre mais l'essentiel était de
faire tourner le groupe et donner leur
chance aux joueurs qui ne jouent pas
forcément championnat comme le jeune
gardien de but des chocs benoît robin
habituelle doublure de mathias vie une
inexpérience ajouté à quelques déchets
en sortie de zone ou aux shoots ont
rendu de nombreux palais au félix les
points à travailler ça va être notre
sortie de zone
notre placement défensif et puis aussi
jeu quand on shoote à la cage touché la
cage on a chanté à des tas de moments ce
qui était positif c'est qu'on a un
niveau de l'intensité physique on a
répondu à jeu égal avec une n2 donc ça
c'est très positif
après c'est sûr que il faut qu'on marque
plus il faut considérer non
ça a été fait qu'un défaut ce serait là
les sharks ont pu se rendre compte de
l'écart de niveau entre les deux
championnats même si à l'arrivée le
score est un peu sévère 12 à 2 la
parenthèse coupe de france s'est donc
vite refermée place au championnat qui
reste la priorité des joueurs de
benjamin ferran